well the uk has lost an extraordinary
public servant in prince philip
he dedicated his life to our country
and above all i think he'll be
remembered for his support
and devotion to the queen and all of our
thoughts are with the queen
the royal family and the british public
as they come together to mourn this
huge loss i always really really enjoyed
spending time with the duke of edinburgh
and talking to him of course i don't
pretend that i knew him well but i met
him
on many different occasions uh
particularly at
balmoral and he was very very different
to the public characterization
that we often heard and read about he
was a very thoughtful man
an exceptionally interesting man to talk
to
he had a strong interest in northern
ireland and i had the privilege of
meeting him here
on a number of his many visits he had a
profound
and positive impact on thousands of our
young people who find their purpose
passion and place in the world through
participation in the duke of edinburgh
awards
throughout his long life prince philip
served
with selfless devotion and a remarkable
generosity of spirit
on behalf of the welsh government and
people in all parts of wales i offer our
deepest condolences
to her majesty the queen her majesty's
children
and their families on this sad
occasion the duke of edinburgh will be
sorely missed
by the many welsh organizations
that he supported as patron or president
over so many decades of service
well i think the whole nation is in
mourning at the loss of prince philip
and my thoughts and prayers are with her
majesty the queen who has
lost the man who was her strength and
stay for over 70 years
prince philip was a remarkable man a man
of many interests and he put
those interests and his talents to the
service the selfless
and committed service of the queen and
the country
i think we have so much to be grateful
to him for
probably more than many will ever know